we're gonna pause and bring you to a
news conference now underway officials
in Maryland briefing us on the shooting
here it is secured to building we are in
the process of notifying the next-of-kin
we have five confirmed fatals and two
injuries the injuries my understanding
are superficial possibly from glass from
the shotgun blast we are working on now
securing his residence he does live in a
state of Maryland we are in the process
of securing that residence and preparing
for search warrants so this is the next
phase of this scene and that is the
investigative phase this is the part
that takes the most time as I would
assume many of you have already heard
from many other police agencies in the
state of Maryland and across the country
the investigative process is very
difficult we must be thorough that's why
you will not get the information from
social media from us unless it's been
confirmed we have allowed our
investigators to do their job they are
there now and we are going to continue
to provide you with information I want
to hold on one second I want to share
something with you that thinks important
we mentioned before about the improvised
explosive device that is not an IAD it
was actually canisters of smoke grenades
that he used inside of the building when
he entered the establishment so this
person was prepared today to come in
this person was prepared to shoot people
his intent was to cause harm
and as I stated before the investigative
part of this is going to be thorough and
it's going to take some time as you can
see behind us we opened up fest Gate
Road
we thought that we may need to secure
that roadway for a long period of time
and as we get further into the
investigation we realize that we don't
need that roadway but the building 888
vest gate will be secured for some time
I do not have a time frame on that yet
we're going to be inside there for quite
a bit and until this investigation is
complete when I have more confirmed
information I will share that confirmed
information with you that's what we're
investigating now that's what I'm
hearing but before we confirm that I
need our investigators to go and look
into that and make sure that's correct
no I can't share that with you it's the
first time I've heard facial recognition
I can't answer that he is at our
Criminal Investigation Division our
detectives are down there with them
I have not interrupted them to ask him
if he's being cooperative you will have
the information as soon as we confirm
the Oni connection I can tell you about
right now is possibly possibly through
social media I have no other
confirmation we are still looking into
that I cannot confirm whether or not our
department has come in contact with them
we will have that at a later time as
well he's a resident of Maryland that's
going to be part of the investigation I
can't confirm for you whether or not he
actually knew employees there or if he
just targeted the business in general I
don't have that information
I can't confirm that they were shot on
the first floor yet I cannot is the
first I heard facial recognition and the
first that I've heard anything about
fingerprints
we have no verification on either I
can't confirm that we know that there
were threats sent to the Gazette through
social media he's in his late thirties
no the threats were sent over social
media we're trying to confirm what
account that was and we're trying to
confirm who actually sent them we're
going to continue to monitor that press
conference in Annapolis Maryland police
obviously describing the horrifying
shooting this afternoon at the Annapolis
newspaper five dead similar number
injured